- I found out, you've
been married for 36 years?
- It'll be 37 in May.
- 30, wow!
(audience cheers)
Like that's incredible.
That's kind od unheard
of in this industry.
How do you do it, how do you stay,
'cause I'm married, and
I love my husband truly,
but there's still moments
where you're like,
"You're driving me nuts."
And he has those plenty as well.
- Well we just drive each other nuts,
and don't get divorced.
(audience laughs)
- (laughs) Stitch that on pillow!
It's like--
- Well we're, you know I
mean, a joke I always say
is we're both very stubborn,
and the only way out of
this is on the horizontal.
- Oh my husband and I are
very stubborn as well.
- Yeah, but you know, I
got lucky, I adore my wife.
I met her first week of Freshman
year in college, you know?
- [Kelly] Aw that's cool.
- And we didn't go out right away,
which I was too, so too nervous and geeky,
no one would have gone out with me,
but so we had a few years where we--
- You were too busy in the
stairwells singing with guys.
(audience laughs)
You're like--
- You know what's funny?
I met her in a stairwell!
(audience applauds)
- She was like, "Who's that guy singing?"
- It sounds like all I do
is hang out in stairwells.
But look what happens.
- You know what,
- There's magic
in those stairwells.
- If you're single,
and loo for love, find a stairwell
that doesn't look like a
Dateline special is gonna happen.
Yes.
(audience laughs)
- She was going up, she
was coming down the stairs
to go out with some guy, and
I was going up the stairs
to see a girl, and we passed,
not a word was spoken.
I remember to this day,
she had platform shoes on,
bell bottoms, tight, and the glitter belt.
- I love her, yeah.
- It was a disco era!
And she is an amazing dancer,
and she would look so cool,
and I was like, oomp a
doomp a doomp a doomp.
(audience laughs)
And I just never, I
don't remember anything,
but I remember that.
- That's so moving.
I remember the first moment
I saw my husband too.
- Do you, it's a nice--
- Yeah.
- It's weird.
- Yeah, I felt like an energy,
it was like crazy, yeah.
- I know, it's weird.
- People say that and
you're like, whatever.
- Whatever, right.
- Until you feel it and you're like,
oh maybe it's real, okay.
- Whoa, maybe it's yeah.
- Yeah, you're like,
- That's right.
- All right, all right.
- Okay, maybe there's something to that.